- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Hello, Rosie.
- [Voiceover] Hello, David.
- [Voiceover] We're gonna
talk about dependent
and independent clauses.
Full disclosure, this
is a relatively advanced
part of grammar, but it is
important to understand,
because mastering dependent
and independent clauses
and being able to say
why a clause is dependent or independent
will help you become a better writer,
will help you become a stronger writer,
and give your sentences
vim and vigor and strength.
So with all that out of the way.
Let's start with independent clauses,
because an independent clause
is basically a sentence.
We established previously
that all a clause is
is just a collection of phrases
with a subject and a verb.
So, for example, the sentence,
I ate the pineapple, period,
is an independent clause.
So, it's a couple of phrases,
we've got this noun phrase I,
we've got this verb
phrase ate the pineapple,
and together that becomes a subject
and verb or a predicate.
So, Rosie, what is a dependent clause?
- [Voiceover] So dependent
clause is different
from an independent clause in that
it can't stand on its own as a sentence.
So it includes a subject and a verb,
but it can't be its own sentence.
And sometimes it might
look like a sentence,
it could start with something
like a subordinating conjunction,
like the word because,
for example, because it was delicious.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
And let's be clear here, you know,
obviously, this is an
utterance that people say.
You know, if you ask me
why did you eat the pizza,
I would respond by saying,
because it was delicious.
Why do we climb the mountain?
Because it is there, you know.
I'm not saying that this is not,
not an utterance that is made
by native speaking English speakers.
It is, of course it is.
But you have to be aware
that it is a dependent clause
and therefore a sentence fragment.
And part of natural informal speech
is that we do use a lot
of sentence fragments.
And sentence fragments are not as common
in formal writing.
You may sometimes use them for effect,
but I want you to remember
that these videos are
about standard American English,
and a kind of formal version
of standard American English.
And so, we're trying to
teach you to distinguish
between independent and dependent clauses
so that you can use them skillfully
in the full knowledge and
mastery of your choices.
You gotta learn your scales
before you can improvise.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Dig?
- [Voiceover] Dig.
- [Voiceover] So because it
was delicious, not a sentence.
This is a dependent
clause, because it begins
with this subordinating
conjunction because.
You could also work in
something like although,
or while, and any of these would
make it a dependent clause.
Now, if it was just on
its own, it was delicious,
yeah, of course, that is a sentence.
The part that makes it dependent is
this subordinating conjunction.
You put that onto the front of it
and all of a sudden it
needs an independent clause
to lean up against.
I know this is confusing,
so let's take a look
at a couple more examples
of independent and dependent clauses.
So, the following are
independent clauses, Rosie.
- [Voiceover] The bear roared.
Maureen pointed out the monster.
That's not our pet rabbit.
- [Voiceover] And let's
do some dependent clauses,
and then you can see
that we'll be able to
combine them into sentences.
- [Voiceover] While the salmon flopped.
That she saw last night.
Unless I'm mistaken.
- [Voiceover] So you can see
that these are all clauses,
right, we've established that, you know,
each one has a subject and a verb.
The bear roared, the salmon flopped.
But all of these have some kind of,
everything in orange has something
that's either a subordinating conjunction
like while or unless, or a
relative pronoun like that.
So while the salmon flopped.
You can see in this context
the bear roared while the salmon flopped,
you can kind of understand
why this is called
the dependent clause,
because by the context
of this sentence, while
the salmon flopped,
something else was going on, right.
This is kind of like
background information.
And it's in fact not necessary
for comprehending the first
sentence or the first clause,
the independent clause, the bear roared.
And if we did combine
these, you would realize
that the salmon flopped is
just background information.
- [Voiceover] Right.
But we need to know what else is going on
for there to be a while.
- [Voiceover] So the bear roared
is a perfectly sensical
sentence on its own.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] And while the
salmon flopped is providing us
with this extra information.
The bear is roaring
while the salmon flopped.
But if we were just to see the sentence
while the salmon flopped on its own,
like say, we didn't have the bear roared,
it would make less sense.
- [Voiceover] Right, because
the presence of this word while
indicates that something
else is also going on,
that's what makes it dependent.
So we need to have the bear roared.
Likewise, Maureen pointed out the monster,
that sentence works fine on its own.
That she saw last night,
sure there's a subject
and there's a verb, she and saw, right,
she saw something, she saw that,
but this relative pronoun needs
to refer back to something,
and that makes it
dependent on the monster.
So this last one's a little tricky, right,
because you might be looking and saying,
well, unless I'm mistaken,
where's the verb?
Well, the verb is kind of hiding in here.
So unless I am mistaken, right.
So, the presence of this
subordinating conjunction unless
makes this into a dependent clause.
So unless means it's kind of hinging
on some other information.
So the other information is
that's not our pet rabbit,
unless I'm mistaken.
I feel that there should be a comma here,
so I'm gonna put one in.
That's not our pet rabbit,
unless I'm mistaken.
I hope this has cleared some stuff up.
So an independent clause
is a subject and a verb
and it can be a sentence.
A dependent clause is
a subject and a verb,
but also a subordinating conjunction
and it cannot be a sentence.
You can learn anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Rosie out.